hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
welcome to our
gaming performance comparison between
the brand new
oneplus 9 pro and of course the iphone
12 pro max now this isn't just any
gaming
comparison i'm actually going to be
comparing the battery life
so i'm going to start each phone with
100
battery and then i'm going to play one
full hour
to see what we end up with so in this
video we're going to be playing three
different games
league of legends wild rift which i've
been waiting for for a long time
then call of duty mobile and of course
the very tough
gentian impact so as you guys can see
right here i've set the iphone to about
80 percent
brightness and i've matched it on the
oneplus 9. the oneplus 9 pro is
currently at 100 battery life so i'm
gonna start with this phone first and
while i'm playing on the oneplus
i'm gonna be charging the iphone up to
100 and then i'm going to do another
hour
on this one now before we begin i do
want to mention that the iphone's chip
is about 15
faster in terms of the cpu and over 40
faster in terms of the graphics however
the oneplus 9 pro does have a really
nice
new cooling system so we're gonna see if
it's gonna be more reliable the first
game we're gonna play is cod mobile here
we are in the graphics settings we have
the frame rate set to max
very high graphics quality ragdoll off
anti-aliasing on
this is very interesting i'm used to the
iphone which has
the square and flat edges this feels
really nice
i kind of miss the iphone 11 because it
feels really nice in your hand it kind
of wraps around and i've got to say i
love the hole punch right here in the
corner
it's literally so hard to notice this
display
looks really really good
got him got him
yeah oh
i got lucky there double kill oh there's
a dude here i know
oh come on yeah all right so far the
performance has been
excellent no drop frames no issues
but yeah i've got to say i love this
display speakers so far really nice that
hole punch
excellent
sick oh look at that all right watch
this
hey
hey all right there you go mvp
that was fun that was around 20 minutes
playing cod mobile
but now let's go over to the next game
but you guys are going into the future
and we're switching to the iphone let's
play some multiplayer
and let's do some ranked display looks
great the only issue is that notch
boom got him oh yeah the notch is a
little bit annoying
oh snipe from the back dude that guy's
got to be up there yep he's on the roof
all right we're going on the roof boys
got him so far performance on the iphone
just as good as the oneplus
i'd say the notch is the one annoying
thing and the bezels also
aren't as thin as the oneplus you do get
a little bit
bigger bezels
yes got the kill cam
look at that headshot headshot
boom the back of the phone does not feel
hot at all
is barely even warm
right that was pretty fun but i want to
do one more thing i want to play
gun fight sniper oh we're so dead
oh this is it yes
did you see that i got him
that was sick look at that kill cap man
oh beautiful boom that was fun
let's go to the oneplus all right here
we are back on the oneplus 9 pro
league of legends wild rift right here
the open beta
finally came to north america so let's
go into the settings
and the one thing that i changed was
switching to performance
60 fps mode and that's it all right i'm
gonna play some
sona
got him barely well my jungle had to
sacrifice himself for that one but yeah
whatever
come on dude get out of here i actually
really like this i like this mobile
version that they made
the map is smaller so everything goes by
really fast
got him man they did a good job on this
game
gotti this is fun
oh so close
oh literally just went straight for me
come on
all right that was about 20 minutes
playing league wild rift and the
performance was great 60 fps the entire
time
no issues at all so really impressed
with the oneplus 9 pro
so far so let's move on league of legos
wild
ripped we're just switching it to 60 fps
not changing anything else
you know what blitzcrank
oh we got him sick
you did really good performance on both
of these games so far
[Music]
boom
boom you got this bro you got this i'll
save you
[Music]
boom give me that blue buff i need blue
buff man all right this has been awesome
good job
[Music]
boom
sick watch this
dude you're so dead bro
yeah boys
[Music]
nice oh you guys are going for the kill
going for the win let's go
yeah they got it that was fun seven
kills one death not bad for a blitz all
right gentian
impact this right here is gonna be the
real test
i'm gonna do everything on high 60 fps
here we go so far everything looks great
a little bit of drop frames there this
game looks really good getting a couple
of weird glitches here for some reason
i'll need amber for this
boom boom flame on bro
oh snap get out of here
so far so good performance pretty good
at these graphic settings
so i've gotta pop these dudes looks like
pop oh come on man there you go
there you go dead bro let's go
nice this is a pretty fun game this is
the closest to
the real mmo rpg you're gonna get on
mobile now the important thing here is
that i haven't really noticed
any uh display dimming yet
gotti i'm really surprised because even
with this game the back of the phone
does not feel very hot in the
performance
no issues at all so far so really liking
it
all right guys so it's been a full hour
on the oneplus 9 pro as you can see
1055 and we are at 77
battery life all right gentian impact on
the iphone
this is where there's actually going to
be a difference we're going to set it to
high and 60. alright so previously we
did experience some dimming
in this game on the iphone so let's see
if we get that
again boom
that's what kills it nice and snappy
performance
disappear disappear bro i am feeling the
back of the phone
i want to see if it's going to dim it is
definitely getting hot i'm not really
noticing any differences in terms of you
know drop
frames performance
oh the display just dimmed i don't know
if you guys saw that but i caught it
that's definitely an issue
with the iphone and to be honest apple's
gotta fix that they've gotta add vapor
chamber cooling as we know the ipad air
has the same a14 chip
as these iphones and it gets much better
graphics performance
and of course that's because the cooling
on this thing
is not good and i am noticing some weird
glitches every once in a while
this dude fell off whoa
it damned like crazy look at it it's so
dark i literally can barely see anything
right now
it is so dark that is
bad that's an issue you do not want this
wow that's dim
all right guys and with that it's been a
full hour on the iphone just like we did
for the oneplus 9 pro
we did have that dimming but let's check
out the battery life
84 battery life wow
so the iphone's doing better alright
guys so it's been two
full hours of gaming and now let's move
on to the conclusion
in terms of the gaming performance they
were both very very good until we got to
genshin
impact the iphone's display dimmed
massively like super super bad because
it started overheating
and because of that we started having a
pretty crappy game experience because
you could barely see the display
and on top of that i was noticing a
little bit of glitches
probably because of the overheating so
the chip is clocking down as well so
that's a major issue for the iphone
whereas on the oneplus 9 pro the new
large vapor cooling
system does a very good job at keeping
it cool and
overall the gaming performance was
better on this phone and those three
games i've got to say
were very very fun and the displays on
both of these phones
are really good but i gotta say that the
hole punch on the oneplus 9 pro is
definitely
better for gaming the bezels are thinner
so i'd say the display experience
better on the oneplus 9 pro as well now
the only other difference was the
battery life the oneplus 9 pro was left
with
77 of the battery while the iphone had
84 so it's gonna give you longer
hours of gameplay unless you're playing
gentian impact where the gaming
experience sucks because it dims
that's a huge problem but for the other
games and probably a lot of other games
out there
the iphone is going to be just fine but
now to answer the main question
which phone is better for gaming
specifically
it's definitely the oneplus 9 pro
because it's more reliable you do not
get any dimming
so i would definitely choose this phone
if i just wanted to game so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe
and definitely check out our hands-on
comparison between these phones
right over there or the unbiased camera
comparison
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the next video